خمسة توربينات دقيقة تعمل بالوقود الكيروسين ،
هيكل خارجي واحد يناسب خوذة مزودة بكاميرا ،
تاجر زيت واحد أصبح مخترعًا مهووسًا ،
قام بربطها بمفرده ،
تشعر بالوزن الذي تذهب إليه للقيام بفحص الأنظمة ، حيث
تقوم شاشة عرض الرؤوس
بالضغط ، مما يؤدي إلى الوصول إلى القوة الكاملة ،
تشعر أن الدفع يأتي  ثم هناك
تلك اللحظة السحرية عندما يسير كل شيء
بهدوء عندما
تترك الأرض قدميك حرفيًا ثم هناك هذه
اللحظة الغريبة التي تشبه إلى حد ما ركوب الدراجة
ولكن في ثلاثة أبعاد حيث يكون
لديك حرية ثلاثية الأبعاد كاملة ،
يمكنك فقط النظر بعيدًا كما تريد  بالذهاب إليه وقد
حدث أنه ليس معجبًا كبيرًا بتلقيه
لقب الرجل الحديدي ، ولكن حتى أنه يواجه
صعوبة في تجنب المقارنات ، لذلك
لم نبني هذا لبناء بدلة الرجل الحديدي ،
فقد كانت هناك بعض أوجه التشابه الرائعة
و Iron Man CGI
تواصل المجتمع معنا بفرح ونحن
متحمسون جدًا لرؤية أنه اتضح أن
كل تفكيرهم الذي فعلوه
حول ما قد يكون عليه الأمر كان في
الواقع شديد  دقيق ، إنه
رابط رائع أحب أن يفعله الناس عندما
يرونه ، فلماذا أترك الوظيفة اليومية
كتاجر نفط لدي بعض التردد في
تحقيق قفزة من وظيفة يومية جيدة تمامًا
إلى هذا العالم ، ولكن
مرة أخرى أعتقد أنك فقط  عش الحياة
مرة واحدة ولا أريد أن أشعر
بالأسف لعدم متابعة هذا الأمر الذي كان يتعلق به ،
هل يمكنك إعادة تخيل رحلة الإنسان
بطريقة مختلفة تمامًا عن طريق إضافة
القليل من القدرة الحصانية إلى الهيكل البشري
، حيث إن القوة الحصانية الصغيرة تشبه إلى حد كبير
خمس طائرات  كل منها بقوة
مائة وسبعين حصانًا قادرة على
ضخ الهواء بسرعة ألف ميل في
الساعة ، أي قوة حصانية أكبر لكل طائرة مما
أطلق عليه هذا ريتشارد بدلته دايدالوس علامة
واحدة بعد هذا الرجل ، يبدو الأمر سهلاً هنا
ولكن لا يوجد ألم لا مكسب صحيح نحن
مررنا بتكرارات لا حصر لها مع هذا ،
حاولنا وضع المحركات
على الأرجل ، وحاولنا وضع ثلاثة
محركات على كل ذراع ، حتى أننا
جربنا التحكم المستقل في الخانق
لكل محرك بالطريقة الوحيدة التي مررنا بها
كل هذا كان فقط من خلال
التحليل المستمر لما يمكن أن يكون أسوأ ما
يمكن أن يحدث إذا خرجنا
للتو وجربناه وإذا كانت هذه الإجابة
تسقط من على بعد قدمين إلى
مزرعة فقمنا بها وفعلناها وهذا هو
سبب فتحنا  الباب على
عالم لم نتخيله أبدًا أن Daedalus
ليس جاهزًا للمرآب الخاص بك ،
لكننا نقوم ببعض العمل مع
مجموعات عسكرية مثيرة للاهتمام حول العالم ،
المستجيب الأول وهو أفراد
إنقاذ بنفس الطريقة إذا كنت تريد
نقل  جندي بطريقة ذكية وفريدة من نوعها للغاية
في الفضاء ثلاثي الأبعاد ، يمكننا أن
نتضح أنه يمكننا القيام بذلك بشكل جيد للغاية ، لكنني
أيضًا أقول إن تركيزنا في
الوقت الحالي هو الترفيه بصراحة عن الناس
، وفي الوقت الحالي المتعة جيدة